hey drew this is bashir chef and
advocate here in toronto today i'm
sharing with you one of my favorite and
all-time recipe it's going to be a beet
tartare showcasing you the
intersectionality between local food and
diversity come along and cook with me
take some oil add into our beets
sprinkle in a little bit of a salt
make a little bundle
and bake it in the oven until they
become really tender approximately 45
minutes to an hour so now my beets came
out of the oven allowed them to cool off
i peeled them and just with the box
grater i just grate them on the larger
setting now i'm going to add my butter
chopped onions and at the same time
we're gonna also add berbere this is the
staple of ethiopian cooking so if you
like food that has a lot of a flavor
aroma and with a little bit of a heat on
it but it's the place to go i'm gonna
add my beets
a good pinch of salt and then i'm going
to be glazing with some fresh orange
juice our beets have the chance to
reduce there is no more orange juice so
i will take my shiso leaves my anger has
been in the oven it turned into a crisp
and i'm going to add a little bit of a
bit on top of it the best way to really
complement this sweetness and the heat
will be accentuating it with a little
bit of orange zest drew i really hope
that you enjoyed this canadian dish my
beet anjera shiso with a little bit of
orange to the next one cheers
[Music]
you